joining us now michael knowles of the
daily wire host of the michael knowles
show you know Hollywood loves to slam
the president for as they put it
dividing the country and yet they put
out a movie like this of course I live
in Hollywood and it truly is gomorrah by
the sea but i actually disagree with the
criticism of this movie in particular i
think it is admirable that hollywood is
finally admitting what we have all seen
far too clearly this week which is that
liberal elites genuinely detest their
fellow countrymen who are conservative
you know there was a CNN contributor
watch a hot ally who said that a public
call to murder Mitch McConnell gave him
faith in the country former CNN
contributor and current cannibal Reza
Aslan publicly called for the murder of
senior counselor to the president
Kellyanne Conway
this week I mean this has been shown
again and again mainstream liberals
mainstream Democrats all the way up to
Joe Biden who is openly condemning the
president and consequently half of the
country as white supremacists we are
seeing that the not just the fringes but
the mainstream left in this country
genuinely despises conservatives that
Hollywood didn't invent this they didn't
come up with the title deplorable that
was Hillary Clinton in 2016 who called
half her countrymen deplorable and
irredeemable art is supposed to reflect
life and from what we've seen of this
movie it seems that it's actually doing
a pretty good job of reflecting the
political situation in this country so
is that why NBC Universal is so
politically tone-deaf that they're only
willing to suspend the promotional
campaign but apparently they're still
gonna release the movie of course I hope
they do release the movie I mean NBC
Universal is putting it on they probably
have an insight or track into how
liberal elites really view half of their
countrymen because they own NBC News and
MSNBC News I think this is a movie that
conservatives should encourage to be
released it shows that disdain that that
we have long suspected is true of our
liberal elites it doesn't cut both ways
for conservatives viewing liberals in
this country you don't see movies in the
other direction because conservatives
don't actually want to go down there we
don't have these sick fantasies about
liberals in this country
but the mainstream left genuinely does
we've seen it for this whole past week
and I look forward to seeing the movie
it's it's quite similar to you know the
Hollywood actors the Liam Neeson's of
the world who who blasts individual gun
ownership for instance but then have
guns featured in every single scene of
the movies that they make of course its
total hypocrisy and you've seen the
hypocrisy in the reaction not just to
this movie but the reaction to those
tragic shootings that occurred a week
ago which is we're told that we need to
tone down the rhetoric we need to tone
down the hatred we need to have love for
our fellow countrymen but just look at
the vitriol that has poured out all week
from people on Twitter all the way up to
Mika Brzezinski on MSNBC who said that
President Trump wants more of these
white supremacists mass shootings all
the way up to presidential candidates
but that is the reality that's going on
here and there is so much tripe that
comes out of Hollywood so many ways in
which Hollywood tries to portray
leftists as good and Noble and wonderful
and perfect and virtuous and
conservatives is awful and deplorable
and I think here you're actually seeing
that script flip whether it's because of
some bizarre fantasy that leftist
Hollywood has or because they're
actually intuiting the culture but
either way I totally welcome it'd be
fascinating to see whether anybody at
NBC Universal is watching your or your
thoughts and what decision they make
about whether it actually released this
film or not Michael Knowles from the
daily while wire Michael thank you